luke tom and jake here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today
we're camping in scotland
[Applause]
[Music]
well guys we're here in the hebrides
islands of scotland and we've got a fun
camping adventure planned we're gonna go
exploring a castle we're gonna do some
hiking and camping some fishing you guys
excited
look at this
is that
look at that old school that's cool
oh i feel so good
[Music]
welcome to barrymore's farm shop look at
guys they've got curiosity cola
dandelion burdock okay we're gonna get a
get a rose lemonade all right let's do
one
there's one scoop that
here's one for you
i wanna get that i kind of do would this
be cool for winter camping
smells good okay
okay tom you're carrying that yeah
yeah don't spill on it
it's a lemon polenta it's kind of like a
sweet lemony cornbread
i'm experiencing being a sheep
it's a tom in sheep's clothing
that looks huge
that's all good
all right a lot of people don't realize
this but scotland is one of the best
places in the world to go camping not
only is it wild and beautiful and open
it also has the best camping laws
anywhere here in scotland you can go on
private land or public land without
needing any permits or permission you
can hike bike even camp build campfires
all that stuff is completely legal
whether the land is private or public
as long as you use some good common
sense and practice and leave no trace
camping you can go wherever you want and
explore this beautiful country you can
also fish in the salt water and gather
shellfish along the shore without
needing a license or permission it's
really one of the few places in the
world where you can just put on a
backpack and go anywhere your feet can
take you
and the sheep have little black
mustaches and swastikas on their side
and he says look
they're nazi zombie sheep yeah and the
[ __ ] the sheep go
which is how german sheep say brains you
guys look look
there's a shipwreck there on the beach
oh yeah it's an old wooden boat
yeah
oh wow the deck collapsed
look at these these are the old square
nails they were square that's the old
days how they made them
yeah
there's a piece of pie oh that is a
piece of pottery look at that that's the
top of one probably from the ship
it's got abandoned
time to see this
they would take sheep's wool and dip it
in tar and they would jam it in between
the wood and that's what keep the water
out you can see this is the the tar
and the wool
that's cool
well that was cool we still got some
hiking to do we gotta keep going
oh look at the cute little fuzzy sheep
look at that old building you want to go
check it out
yeah i think this is a little old
well this is just how they make windows
when you're making a house out of rocks
make the windows with a little bit of
slade
all right jake open it up
love it it's all downhill from here whoa
yeah that's going to feel good
all right jay can you shut that shut the
gate
um
andy with that he opens the pub door
steps outside in the darkness and says
see mcgregor there is no zombie sheep i
don't know what that
half a dozen nazi zombie sheep grab
shane and pull him into the darkness and
his screams are muffled only by the
bleeding sounds of the angry nazi
fascist zombie sheep
okay watch out sorry don't do it stop
stop do you take
yeah poop does look like chocolate jacob
yeah
look at this guys
[Music]
hey do you guys want to explore the
beach a little bit before we go up to
the castle
bye
oh really
no we're not local
that's the people that own this land
that we're crossing and turns out
they're outdoor boys fans so uh we gotta
we gotta beat some fans here in scotland
in scotland you're allowed to cross
people's land and camp on it so they're
like oh yeah sure yeah everywhere
anybody can do that just be respectful
of people's land don't leave your litter
and they're well you're welcome to come
and camp on it
oh look
uh check it out it's a little snail
called a winkle
these are edible and uh
this uh also edible
it's actually really good it
tastes like salty garden peas
some limpets
yeah
nice size limpet
what was your reaction
little piece of raw limpet
oh look at the size of that
that's a big one
sheep bone
let's keep going to the castle
this castle is almost 500 years old
let's see maybe it's blocked off or
maybe it's just to keep the sheep out
oh when you push this down you can move
oh look at that oh
stairs that went up
the fireplace
oh this is awesome
this castle was destroyed in battle
during the coveting wars around the
1700s the mcdougall clan had this castle
and uh they ended up having to surrender
because of lack of water and they were
promised if they surrendered they
wouldn't be killed and they surrendered
and then they just murdered everybody
i see red stuff
yeah
these windows
absolutely gorgeous spot for a castle
and you can see why it'd be so hard to
defeat this thing you're not getting up
these cliffs
yep
check out the walls with the
the arrow slits and stuff
yeah that would be dirty business trying
to attack this castle
would you like to go down to the beach
and see if we can build a fire
yeah
all right maybe we can do some fishing
too come on let's do it
no no there's plenty of poop down there
you don't need to carry any poop
[Music]
well listen guys do you want to build a
little campfire
well uh what's there to burn
is there any wood
any trees maybe we can burn the sheep
like
you could do with the buffalo poo
i think maybe you're right you got you
need the stuff that's super dry
like see this oh that's gross you you
now that's not a dry one that's that's
juicy see this see how this one's dry on
the top
it's a little wet on the bottom but it's
dry on the top
let's collect some poop
i'm not collecting come on you want to
collect
food do not jake make a poo pile but
only the dry stuff see that's a wet one
go get all the poops that are dry and
put them there
see here
see look at this do you know what this
is
this is dry kelp here
tommy make a big pile right here see you
right there
nice piece of wood
i need your help on this
[Music]
that little spoon rigged up we got on
these rocks and see if we can't catch a
bullet
look at that beautiful little fish
look at that that's such a pretty fish
i've already gotten like six or seven
strikes in ten casts there's tons of
them in here
there we go
beautiful
you got it
lift up your tip lift you up to your tip
oh
wow look at that that's a nice little
pull look
can this be mine would you rather eat
that or hot dogs oh i would rather eat
this well let you eat this pollock
that's a nice one oh here we go
yeah i'll take
you okay oh jake
oh did you play in the tide pool
and you got all wet
oh okay well we better go get you warmed
up well jake's wet and tom's hungry i
think it's time to go take our fish and
go make some dinner well let's get a
fire going okay
there you go jake are you warmer
well in addition to that little fish we
caught we have some interesting food to
eat tonight i figured we would have some
classic hot dogs so i've got hot dogs in
a can
yeah that's right they sell hot dogs in
jars and cans out here i also brought
along this disposable barbecue they have
these all over the place here in the uk
so i figured i'd give one a go
yes
now unfortunately i don't have a lot of
ketchup is that okay
you got this little canned spaghetti
noodles like this
raw yeah well here it's a
spaghetti dog
you guys like your hot dogs
got some welsh cakes here
top
welsh butter on a welsh cake
there you go
oh look at that
some fresh pollock
can i get much fresher than that hey do
you want some of this
[Applause]
i swear it looks like someone's been
here with a lawn mower this sheep just
trimmed the grass so perfectly you know
i'm not surprised golf was invented in
scotland the whole land looks like a
golf green
well it was a bit of a hike it's where
we had our campfire right down there
whoo would i ever bring
head upstairs i'll bring up the stuff
[Music]
here tom
here
hey guys you can take a seat on the
sheep
tonight would you like some dessert mini
battenburg cakes i love these battenberg
cakes it's like cake jam and almond
flavored fondant around it they are
amazing
you know the historic sites are nice but
it's things like this that keep me
coming back to the uk oh thank you oh
yeah
are you guys full
do you want to eat another cake yes it's
getting late
listen do you guys want to sleep here
tonight or do you want to sleep outside
the castle
outside it's a bit spooky isn't it so
apparently it was the campbell clan that
burned and sacked this castle and
murdered all of its occupants after they
surrendered and uh coincidentally that's
the clan that i'm related to so uh
yeah so we're just gonna hang out here
for a little bit i'm gonna watch the
show with the boys and then i'm gonna go
pitch the tent out front and uh we're
gonna camp there
all right
watch out guys
i'll try to be atlanta yeah obi-wan
kenobi's scottish so we should we should
watch obi-wan kenobi today right guys
kidnap an imperial senator's child all
right guys it's late we gotta get to bed
i'll see you guys in the morning
[Music]
sun gets up early here in scotland and
i'm just enjoying
this view
it's so beautiful
but uh i'm gonna go ahead and get some
breakfast made while the boys sleep in
and i brought along a bottle of gelled
sterno here and i'm going to take one of
these tin cans we used last night and
see if i can't make a little camp stove
and cook a bacon sandwich
[Music]
so
nice hot bacon sandwich a little hp
sauce and butter
yeah not too bad and i barely used up
any of my fuel so whenever the boys are
ready i'll cook them some more
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a strawberry rosehip herbal tea i
got here in scotland and it is
wonderful
oh
that's good
well
absolutely no charring no damage
it's exactly the way we want to leave it
thomas jacob
[Music]
you can keep whatever walking stick you
want
here
it's super light all right guys you
ready for the hike back yeah
all right let's do it
uh
[Music]
there you go
thank you very much
thank you you have a great day
listen we had a great time filming this
video and i hope you enjoyed watching it
if you guys want to see our entire
five-week tour of the uk that's england
scotland wales and northern ireland
check out the link in the video
description below i'll put the link
there as soon as i post that video but
thanks for watching we put out new
videos every saturday morning so don't
forget to click subscribe to the outdoor
boys youtube channel if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]